Вітаю! Я Леонід Горобець,
доктор біологічних наук.
І сьогодні проведу урок на тему:
“Види забруднення, їхні наслідки для
природних і штучних екосистем та людини”.
Здається, що термін “забруднення”
не потребує пояснення.
Забрудненням є все, що перебуває
не в тому місці і не в той час.
Наприклад, багнюка на
болоті не є забрудненням,
а ось вже в тарілці вона геть недоречна.
Однак справжнє різноманіття
забруднення значно більше, ніж уявляється.
І сьогодні ми познайомимося з
основними різновидами забруднення.
Перша категорія – механічне забруднення.
До нього належать всі об’єкти,
які вкрай повільно розкладаються:
скло, поліетилен, пластик, брухт тощо.
Деякі з них, як, наприклад, бляшанки
розкладаються за сотні років, деякі
розкладаються за тисячі років, як,
наприклад, деякі різновиди поліетилену.
Основна небезпека об’єктів
механічного забруднення полягає в тому,
що вони надзвичайно довго
перебувають в біосфері.
З часом виникає ймовірність того,
що об’єкт потрапляє в тіло тварин,
зокрема – в травну
систему, дихальну систему
і може призвести до загибелі тварин.
Механічне забруднення
надзвичайно поширене в світі.
Воно є навіть за межами біосфери.
Зокрема довкола Землі зараз літає
чимало, так званого, космічного сміття.
Вчені припускають, що в світовому океані
сумарна кількість об’єктів
механічного забруднення
становить 1 700 000
квадратних кілометрів.
Це надзвичайно велика площа,
співставима по розмірам із
Іспанією та Португалією разом взятих.
Боротьба з механічним забрудненням
покладена на кожного з нас.
Звісно компанії-виробники
об’єктів, які можуть стати
механічним забрудненням,
зобов’язані слідкувати за їх переробкою.
Втім рядові споживачі теж
повинні відповідально ставитися
до таких об’єктів і всіляко
сприяти їх утилізації,
а не самовільному викидуванню в простір.
Інший різновид забруднення,
про який ми рідко задумуємося
– це фізичне забруднення.
Види таких забруднень ви бачите на екрані.
Наприклад, теплове забруднення.
Довкола різноманітних
об’єктів виникають теплові хвилі,
які вивільняються в навколишнє середовище.
А оскільки енергія нікуди не зникає,
то вони діють на навколишнє
середовище, підвищуючи температуру.
Ти, мабуть, помічав, що в містах
температура зазвичай вище,
ніж у лісах навколо міста.
Це саме завдяки тому, що в містах є велика
кількість об’єктів теплового забруднення.
Також різновидом фізичного
забруднення є світлове забруднення.
Над ним ми рідко задумуємося.
Світло – це те, що необхідно людям,
оскільки ми являємося денними істотами.
Проте наші міста
надзвичайно сильно освітлені,
що має негативний вплив на природу:
-Збиваються цикли в рослин;
-Порушуються міграційні
шляхи птахів тощо.
Світлове забруднення діє і
на людей у зв’язку з тим, що
освітлення є фактором
навколишнього середовища,
яке діє на організм іще з самих
перших днів існування біосфери.
Фактично всі організми, окрім
мешканців глибин та печерних екосистем,
адаптовані до зміни дня і ночі.
Деякі з них є денними, деякі –
нічними, деякі – сутінковими тощо.
Ми являємося денними істотами.
Ендокринна система налаштована
на те, щоб ми були вдень активними.
За це відповідає спеціальний
гормон – мелатонін,
який виробляється клітинами
епіфізу головного мозку.
Епіфіз глибоко захований в наш мозок.
Однак світлові промені
доходять до нього завдяки тому,
що скронева кістка досить тонка і
спроможна пропускати світлові промені.
Завдяки цій інформації епіфіз
орієнтується в зміні дня і ночі,
виділяючи гормони, які впливають
на життєдіяльність нашого організму.
Порушення роботи епіфізу
може мати негативні наслідки,
включно до розвитку ракових пухлин.
Інший різновид фізичного забруднення
– це електромагнітне забруднення,
а також – шумове забруднення.
Попри те, що природа їх досить
різна – електромагнітні хвилі,
а також звукові коливання,
між ними чимало спільного.
По-перше, це різновиди забруднення,
які найбільше виражені в містах,
оскільки в містах проходять
численні лінії електропередач,
працює чимало електричних приладів тощо.
Крім того місто має постійний шум,
який відсутній в природніх екосистемах.
Ми звикли до цього виду забруднення
і не звертаємо на нього увагу.
Але при цьому воно
продовжує на нас діяти.
Зокрема, постійне перебування в зоні
електромагнітного та шумового забруднення
має негативний ефект на
діяльність нервової системи,
збільшує ймовірність розвитку стресу,
а також впливає на
шлунково-кишковий тракт та серце.
У зв’язку з цим електромагнітне
та шумове забруднення
може призвести до появи
інфаркту, гастриту, виразки шлунку
та багатьох інших неприємних захворювань
серцево-судинної та травної системи.
Ще одним важливим різновидом фізичного
забруднення є радіаційне забруднення.
Забрудник, якого ми взагалі не помічаємо.
У нас немає жодного органу чуття, який хоч
якось сприймав би радіаційне забруднення.
При цьому радіоактивний
фон наявний скрізь.
З одного боку – це природний процес.
В природі завжди мусить
існувати певний радіоактивний фон.
Більше того, припускають,
що радіоактивність необхідна
для деяких важливих
фізіологічних процесів.
В тому випадку, коли
істоти в лабораторних умовах
вирощувалися при пониженому
радіоактивному фоні,
вони почувалися гірше, ніж за
природного радіоактивного фону.
Однак не слід забувати, що
радіоактивний фон може бути підвищений
і причиною цього може стати
навіть не Чорнобильська катастрофа
або випробування ядерної зброї.
Самий найпростіший спосіб
підвищити радіоактивний фон –
це не провітрювати своє приміщення.
Основним джерелом радіоактивного
фону в природі є газ радон,
який виділяється із
будь-яких материнських порід:
граніту, базальту та всього,
що з них зроблено: бетон,
пісок, цегла, асфальт тощо.
Ми оточені похідними граніту і базальту.
Відповідно довкола нас
постійно виділяється радон.
Цей процес безперервний, природний і
на нього ніяким чином не можна вплинути.
Однак, радон є найбільш
важким газом у повітрі.
І в тому випадку, якщо ми будемо
погано провітрювати приміщення,
він буде накопичуватися у
приміщенні швидше, ніж інші гази,
оскільки він дуже важкий – тим самим
сприяючи підвищенню радіоактивного фону.
За даними Всесвітньої
Організації Охорони Здоров’я,
приблизно 25% випадків
раку легень зумовлені тим,
що люди мешкали в погано
провітрюваних приміщеннях.
Існують інші способи
підвищити радіоактивний фон.
Окрім радону, підвищенню радіоактивного
фону сприяють ультрафіолетові промені.
Тому слід обережно ставитися
до, так званих, сонячних ванн
або перебування незахищеним
в яскраві сонячні дні.
Можна підвищити
радіоактивний фон і штучно.
Наприклад, солярії, занадто часто
ведуть до медичного обстеження тощо.
Звичайно, що однією із категорій
забруднювачів є хімічне забруднення.
Основними джерелами
надходження хімічних викидів
являються різноманітні
промислові викиди, стоки тощо.
Окрім того, це можуть бути
різноманітні побутові відходи:
пролите мастило,
фарба, розчинник до фарб.
Навіть акумулятор від ліхтарика
є дуже потужним джерелом забруднення
навколишнього середовища важкими металами.
Також до різновидів хімічного
забруднення належать пестициди.
Пестицидами називають хімічні сполуки,
які використовуються людьми для боротьби з
іншими, шкідливими для людей організмами.
Зокрема, найбільш
відомі – це інсектициди,
які використовуються для
того, щоб знищувати комах.
Також існують фунгіциди для знищення
грибків та інші різновиди пестицидів.
Сучасне сільське господарство
неможливе без використання пестицидів.
Якщо ми будемо використовувати меншу
кількість пестицидів, в такому випадку
ми недоотримаємо врожай, що
може стати причиною голоду на планеті.
Тому ми вимушені
використовувати ці речовини.
Однак, варто відмітити,
що науковці працюють
над розробкою нових пестицидів,
які менше шкодять
довкіллю, ніж ті речовини,
які використовувалися
50-100 років тому назад.
Особливою категорією
забруднювачів є біологічне забруднення.
До нього належать різноманітні види,
які були переміщені зі свого
природнього середовища в нові умови.
Над цим різновидом
забруднення ми рідко задумуємося.
Здається це настільки
природно – рослини, тварини.
Яким чином вони можуть
бути забруднювачами?
Здається чим більше тварин і
рослин буде навколо, тим краще.
Однак, це не завжди так.
Потрапивши в нові
умови, вид може зустрітися
із цілковитою відсутністю
хижаків або потужних конкурентів.
В такому випадку вид легко розмножується
і починає витісняти інші види,
які мешкали на цій території споконвіків.
У світі надзвичайно велика
кількість небезпечних видів.
Найбільш відома історія
з кроликами в Австралії.
Однак, не лише одними
кроликами багата біосфера.
Зокрема, в Україні яскравими
прикладами біологічного забруднення
являється така рослина як борщівник.
Свого часу її завезли з Кавказу для
того, щоб вирощувати заради силосу –
речовини, якою вигодовують худобу.
Як силосна культура, борщівник
себе погано зарекомендував.
Зате він легко обжив наші території
і зараз є чисельним по
різноманітних біотопах.
Окрім того, що борщівник
витісняє наші українські види,
він може становити
небезпеку і для людини.
Хімічні речовини, які виділяє
борщівник збільшують чутливість шкіри.
Побувши поблизу борщівника, а, тим більше,
доторкнувшись до нього, людина ризикує,
що коли вона вийде на сонячне
проміння – в неї розвинеться великий опік.
Часом на подолання таких
опіків необхідно декілька років.
Шрами зберігаються досить таки довго.
Тож побачивши борщівник,
намагайтеся з ним не контактувати.
Боротися з борщівником необхідно
або в спеціальних захисних костюмах,
або ж дочекавшись,
коли він відквітує і висохне.
Восени його можна
спокійно зрізати і знищувати.
В тому ж випадку, якщо ви випадково
потрапили під дію борщівника,
то уникайте контакту із
прямими сонячними променями.
Також із рослин об’єктом
біологічного забруднення
являється амброзія полинолиста.
Ця рослина досить поширена в
містах України, її пилок літає скрізь
і є потужним алергеном, цим
самим ускладнюючи життя людям,
які чутливі до пилку.
Ще однією рослиною, яка є об’єктом
біологічного забруднення в Україні
є елодея канадська.
Цю водну рослину колись завезли
до нас як акваріумний об’єкт,
проте в подальшому вона
потрапила в навколишнє середовище,
легко прижилась в
наших водоймах і подекуди
утворює надзвичайно великі зарості.
Також чимало об’єктів біологічного
забруднення і серед тварин.
Продовжуючи тему акваріумних
організмів, згадаю таких представників
як головешка-ротань або сонячний окунь
Головешка-ротань – це
мешканець Далекого Сходу,
а сонячний окунь –
мешканець Північної Америки.
В акваріумах вони виглядають
чудово: невеличкі рибки –
ротань до 16 см, сонячний окунь ще менше;
не сильно яскраві, водночас привабливі.
Проте коли вони потрапляють
у природні водойми,
то можуть стати справжнім
лихом. Ці риби є хижаками,
особливо головешка-ротань,
який споживає здобич,
що може бути по розміру до
третини його власних розмірів.
Цим самим винищує молодь риб, ікру тощо.
Сонячний окунь полює на
менші об’єкти, але також виїдає
ікру, малька, а також з’їдає
різних дрібних безхребетних,
цим самим створюючи
конкуренцію нашим рибам.
В морських екосистемах
наявні свої забруднювачі.
Наприклад, відомий всім молюск рапана,
який став вже неофіційним
символом Чорного моря,
його часто використовують на чорноморських
курортах при виготовленні сувенірів.
Але насправді цей молюск потрапив
до нас штучно з Далекого Сходу
із баластними водами різноманітних суден.
Рапана є хижаком і їсть
інших молюсків, зокрема мідій.
Проникнення рапани в Чорне море суттєво
підірвало мідійний промисел
в акваторіях України.
Іншим вкрай небезпечним
об’єктом біологічного забруднення
є реброплав мнеміопсіс.
Це родич медуз, який не має жалких клітин,
на відміну від медуз, і здається
цілком безпечним, невеличким, м’яким.
Однак мнеміопсіс є хижаком.
Він споживає різноманітні дрібні об’єкти,
цим самим підриваючи кормову базу
наших водних мешканців.
На суходолі також наявні
тварини, яких можна вважати
об’єктом біологічного забруднення.
Такі як, наприклад, ондатра,
завезена в Україну з Північної Америки.
Нутрія – гризун, завезений
з Південної Америки.
Єнотовидний собака, який
також завезений з Америки.
Та найбільше варто
відмітити норку американську.
Свого часу її завезли на територію
України як мисливський о’бєкт.
Норка не тільки чудово прижилась,
але й виявилася більш сильною
В конкурентній боротьбі із нашим
видом – норкою європейською.
Конфлікт двох видів норок
проходить безконтактно –
вони не зустрічаються між собою,
не б’ються за територію тощо.
Однак американська норка
краще споживає ресурси,
має більшу пристосованість
до виживання тощо,
завдяки чому вона
захоплює нові і нові території.
Європейській норці залишається
все менше місця, завдяки чому
цей вид занесений до
Червоної книги України.
Також європейська норка під
дією біологічного забруднення
потрапила до Червоного списку Європи.
Є чимало інших об’єктів
біологічного забруднення.
В будь-якому випадку, варто пам’ятати,
що ми повинні відповідально ставитися до
завезення тварин чи рослин
на нові території.
Частково ця відповідальність
покладена на державу.
Зокрема, появу реброплавів
може регулювати тільки держава.
Однак є чимало об’єктів, відповідальність
за яких покладена на окремих громадян.
Достатньо одного акваріуміста
для того, щоб у водоймах
навколо вашого міста з’явився
головешка або сонячний окунь.
Щоб розробляти методи боротьби
з різноманітними забрудниками,
в першу чергу необхідно
ідентифікувати їх.
Для цього в сучасної науки є
цілий різноманітний спектр методів.
Самі прості методи – це
контактні методи спостереження.
Дослідники приходять в середовище,
відбирають проби і досліджують їх.
Часом дослідження може безпосередньо
відбутися вже на самій території.
Інколи для цього необхідні
спеціальні лабораторні дослідження.
Окрім того, на сьогодні існує чимало
дистанційних методів спостереження.
Відстежувати зміну довкілля
цілком можливо навіть з космосу:
за допомогою супутникових знімків, а
також за допомогою спеціальних супутників,
які відстежують рівень викиду теплового
забруднення,
озонові плями тощо.
В будь-якому випадку, після
того, як ми зібрали певні дані,
виміряли забруднення,
виникає питання – а що далі?
Чи є цей показник небезпечним,
чи ситуація цілком нормальна?
Щоб знайти відповідь на це запитання,
необхідно перевірити вплив того
чи іншого забруднення на організм.
Звісно, що на людях
цього ніхто не буде робити.
Для цього використовуються
різноманітні тест-об’єкти:
живі організми (зазвичай це
досить простенькі організми),
такі, як, наприклад, рачок дафнія.
Це мікроскопічний рачок,
приблизно міліметр завдовжки.
Або навіть лусочка цибулі.
І на них перевіряють вплив
того чи іншого забруднювача.
Відстежуючи стан екосистеми, можна
не обов’язково брати хімічні проби.
Можна подивитися які саме об’єкти
мешкають в тій чи іншій екосистемі.
Якщо в ній наявні
дафнії, то, скоріш за все,
що ця водна екосистема не є забрудненою.
Також дуже показовими є
лишайники – надзвичайно чутливі
до хімічного складу повітря.
І ліхеноіндикація, тобто
використання лишайників
для індикації забруднення повітря
є окремим самостійним, простим, дешевим
і водночас ефективним методом індикації.
За результатами досліджень
розробляються показники,
так звані гранично допустимі
концентрації речовин.
В даному випадку є два
підходи щодо встановлення
нормативів вмісту тих чи інших речовин.
Перший підхід – це технологічні нормативи.
В його основу покладено розуміння
технологічного процесу, тобто
знання того – де можна
зменшити кількість забруднення.
І в результаті ми повинні досягнути того,
щоб наші заводи і фабрики
створювали продукцію,
при цьому не завдаючи шкоди довкіллю.
Ті викиди, які при цьому
супроводжуються на виробництві
– не перевищують гранично
допустимих концентрацій.
В тому ж випадку, якщо завод
починає перевищувати нормативи,
можна зменшити обсяги виробництва,
змінити технологічний процес тощо.
Однак такий варіант вдається не завжди.
Є виробництво, яке
неможливе без відходів.
Навіть наше життя на сьогодні
неможливе повністю без відходів.
Можна відмовитися від
поліетилену, від пластику тощо.
Проте кожен із нас, хоче чи не хоче,
все рівно буде продукувати
певну кількість відходів.
Такі напрямки діяльності як,
наприклад, атомна енергетика,
під час вироблення електроенергії
не завдають ніякої шкоди довкіллю,
але стикаються з проблемою
залишку радіоактивних відходів,
які на сьогодні ми не
знаємо – як їх утилізувати.
В такому випадку необхідно
зробити певні сміттєзвалища,
інші місця зберігання відходів,
включно до захоронення цих відходів
і прийняти, що на сьогодні ця
територія, на жаль, буде зруйнована.
Це вкрай небажаний сценарій і тому
до нього вдаються тільки в тому випадку,
якщо розробка технологічних
нормативів виявиться неможливою.
Як бачимо, у світі існує величезна
кількість різноманітних способів
забруднювати навколишнє середовище.
Вирішити проблему можна тільки
на державному і міжнародному рівні.
Проте це не знімає
відповідальності з кожного з нас.
Фактично проблему глобального потепління,
проблему захоронення радіоактивних
відходів громадяни не вирішать самотужки.
Для цього необхідне втручання
міжнародних організацій.
Проте зменшити кількість
механічного забруднення,
випадків біологічного забруднення –
це зможе зробити кожен із нас.
На цьому в мене все. Будьте здорові!